おはよー
一つに
[音楽]
よろしくお願いしまーす
ooooooooooooooooooooo oooo 2
今日はドクターはじめ皆さん美容室行きますか美容2って基本的にまあ月1回つけない
人で2ヶ月3ヶ月に1回ぐらいのペースで美容室に行くと思う
誰が美容室っていうのはもともとそのためだけはなくなってきたなぁと思った髪の毛を
切りに行って理想の髪型になるつまりどんな髪型でも美術に行けば理想の髪型に近づけ
て
くれるということはえっ会ブースに行くと理想の髪型になるじゃないですかあの理想の
髪型でさらに美容室に行くとさらなる理想の髪型に近づく理想の髪だと理想の髪型に
近づけて髪型で別は病室にできるってもらうと二重虹さんの髪型おりそんなたメガネ
近づいた形よりそんな針金近づけた理想の髪型になぜこれをいっぱい繰り返すと
人は完璧な理想のカメラで近づくことができるん
はないかと私は予想したて外で今回は僕のかわいいもロボットで実験になってもの誰に
は1日かけて美容して10カ所に帰ってもらい理想のため方を追求し続けた結果どの
ような髪型になるか
継承していこうと思う平和行こう
ええええええ
坊主になるのかな日頃から飛び握りたい
けっ切りたいと言っていたご様子で今回の実験で理想の髪型に近づけるのでしょうか
おっと最高の試合ですこのままカットを得たいところですがあと9店舗あります今など
どのように変化していくのでしょうかん楽しみです
2店舗目です神だけど長さ的にはまるきりやすいはずすでに完成形であるこの髪型から
どのようなアレンジを加えていくのでしょうか
[音楽]
ああああああ
ここで衝撃の短さ2店舗目でまさかのこの短さ
この先に残り9点峰嫌な未来が見えてきました
端点場面は取りエンド概算おしゃれの店ならではのお洒落なショートヘアに仕上げて
くれるでしょうか
かっこいい髪型ですサイドがかなり短くなっていい感じ
すっきりとしたこの髪型は残念ながら保つことができません次にギア正四電マ女です
さあなかなかも切る場所がないのではこの中でどのようなアレンジを加えてくるのかと
自分の食面ではありますおおっと混ぜ火のカラーチェンジ
黒神からほのかな茶色に押されたら頭皮はいたそうだ
おしゃれに彼ママつきものとはこのことか
[音楽]
午前褒めですさあ色は変わったものの長さでしょうとここからどのような変化が見
られるのでしょうか
方とここでパーマーカーわずかな生き残りの神の木にパーマがかかっている
[音楽]
ni
car
絶妙なオシャレ感が増したがあと5回理容室に行ってもらいます
[音楽]
6.5目ですもはや本人にも美容師さんにも申し訳なくなってきましたが止めるわけに
は行きませんあの後前方に頑張っていきましょうよ
それか区切りますがないと思うんですよねぇー
可能であればはい様子ですね
[音楽]
yeah
parse
pot おしゃれだそれ神だ押されたが透明で見るとあれ
ベロアでがや
はいなら店舗目ですざっ剃り込みも入ったんここから同市いたする
ソニコミクールパターンが考えられますがここは秒者さんのセンスが問われる
それか見なかった臆安全にでオンになってしまいました
よく髪がほぼありません萌え話の方がないパッティ本目ですサイドはもう一度よ中出し
た後は前髪かトップくらいですがどうなるのがもう僕もしれません
[音楽]
あーぬー jk ia ペーパーふぉぼ
ポーズでさあ最後の店舗にバトンを渡されちゃう
はいというわけでようやく9店舗が終わって次がラストの10店舗目になりますこれで
理想に偽装を重ねた上の史上最強に男性の理想の髪型に彼が近づくことができます
ちょっと見ていきましょう
[音楽]
ほぼないですはいというわけで最後の良質で彼はどのような髪型にたどり着くまで昇華
結果とても楽しみですでは行こうさあ最後の美容室です
あとはもうなるようになるのねぇ勝を果たしてまずのはもうじゃなんかそれと
[拍手]
me
[音楽]
re
ああああああ
これ
ここ
どこあっはぁ
いやー
オベ酒と言われ
始め
パパん
気付かれた母
きいろいま
人間の理想の髪型だ
さあアイマスクを取ってくればよい
[音楽]
uh
dea
car
me あった